after the slaughter on the streets of
butcher comes the paperwork
police list as best they can how each
person died and what they were wearing
a difficult task in normal times
but just look at the scale of their
challenge
each bag holds a life violently ended
while russian troops patrolled this town
they have names and families
facts officials are trying to confirm
he's on the phone to a woman whose
husband was killed
do you spell your name abramov
he asks
sergey is in charge of funeral services
his phone is constantly ringing
vladimir putin's spokesman may well have
dismissed claims russian forces killed
civilians in butcher but sergey is in no
doubt
[Music]
russia denies its forces killed
civilians here in butcher but the
ukrainian authorities say that these
bodies around me we've counted 35 body
bags we're all civilians the majority of
them shot dead 12 bodies alone have been
found so far today and the authorities
keep discovering more
a mass grave dug in the shadows of saint
andrews church
testament to more trauma
one official said when this place was a
war zone bodies had to be disposed of
quickly or left in the street
russian troops pulled out of butcher
last week under ukrainian fire
relief
and grief for residents like olena out
with her daughter
she said russian soldiers had killed her
friend valeri
[Music]
the kremlin may want the world to
believe this is fake news
but the evidence of russia's rampage
is all too real
debra haynes sky news butcher